too hot to handle this was like this is
my one of my favorite parts of
self-isolation
I enjoyed this show so much how was the
experience for you if you like the
handle was exactly how it probably was
watching it it was chaotic and it was
interesting they were beautiful people
doing insane crazy things it was
definitely you know once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to be around a bunch of
really good-looking people who were
struggling not to have sex and while we
also were doing very sexual in nature
workshops and activities and it was a
lot it was a lot of fun
this is a chance for you guys to play to
try something new to experiment use your
feelings to your advantage you don't
have to push them down the Toronto
Bourne sexologist also just launched her
own Daily Show on kwibi sexology with
Shan what's the sort of purpose of this
show who do you hope to reach and what
do you hope to say sexology with Shambhu
DRAM is sex education in quick bites
with real people real stories real
advice the other kind of person who's
likely to goes to somebody who is
avoidant Lee attached I hope with the
show that people are getting a lot of
great ideas for their group chats I hope
that they're finding ways to improve
their intimate lives and I hope they're
being entertained while doing it the
ongoing joke has been everybody's
wearing sweatpants for weeks on end it's
not outfit of the day it's at it's
outfit of the week is what it is have
you encouraged somebody you live with to
kind of go back to physically looking
the way they did before all this without
completely offending them I'm a big fan
of the young versus Hyuk encouragement
method right so encouraging them through
the behavior that you like versus being
mean about the behavior that you don't
and by the way I am not wearing socks
dance oh wow are those jeans see right
those are those leather pants no they're
jeans let's not go full leather
hey there jeans I'm not at all wearing
leather pants in the afternoon